all right welcome back everybody 6 42
diabetes affects 34 million americans
and doctors say it is the leading cause
of blindness kidney failure amputation
and stroke and during the pandemic
people with diabetes face much higher
risks for severe complications from
covet 19. joining me to talk about
how families can be helped especially
the kiddos who are now back to school
tasha thatcher she is the development
manager for the nevada diabetes
association tasha thank you so much for
being here how you doing
i am doing wonderful how are you doing
monica i am doing great i'm so glad
you're here today you know i wanted to
talk about this because of course you
know everybody's been talking about the
death of uh iconic rapper bis marquis
that brought diabetes back to you know
the top of
the
conversation
of course his was type 2 but we also
have type 1 out there and also
personally i reversed my diabetes type 2
several years ago but most recently my
doctor said okay you're pre-diabetic
again and it's because i was on lockdown
and i wasn't doing what i was supposed
to do that's stressful to me as an adult
so as a kid i can't imagine what the
kids are going through if they are
diabetic so tell us about the nevada
diabetes association and your role here
in southern nevada
okay well thank you so much for having
me this morning and the diabetes
associated
creation has a program in service for
anyone affected by diabetes in our
community we offer support group
programs for families
teens young adults we have a short-term
emergency medical assistance program for
people in need we have education
programs
diabetes
advocacy programs as well as
camp programs for kids yes i was
checking out your website it looks like
you guys have a lot of fun helping folks
out so let's talk about your partnership
specifically with ccsd and how you guys
help them manage the task of serving the
students you know with diabetes because
of course we know they have to eat
differently specifically when it comes
to managing their health and their diet
on campus and has covert affected any of
that because i know a lot of parents are
interested in how their diabetic
children are being
handled or managed on the school level
right so the nevada diabetes association
is a main
point of resource
for ccsd families um we you know
diabetes is a community
um you know it takes a village yeah and
you know children who uh children and
families are not alone in this journey
with diabetes
and you know we we help the the main
point that we help the families with is
through the support and we do receive
referrals from the clark county school
district nurses
and also some educators for our uh
services in southern nevada yeah and
covet and covet 19 has definitely
changed you know the whole dynamic
of uh you know children in schools
especially children who are living with
diabetes yeah and you know there's
definitely um extra you know families
parents are definitely concerned about
the health and safety but the school
district does have their guidelines and
protocols in place to make sure that all
students are
well taken care of yeah and you guys
like i said i was on your website tasha
it looks like you guys do a lot of fun
stuff you have a lot of fun events some
are adult-friendly events there so can
you talk about that and i'm not sure if
colbot has shut down some of them but
they were on your website so i wanted to
ask you about them
okay so
during the pandemic in 2020 we moved
everything to a virtual platform okay
and we didn't make sure our support
group programs
we worked in conjunction with our reno
family support group and did a
partnership between the two programs to
you know provide diabetes education
topics and you know just let our
community know that we were still there
for them we did um do a virtual camp
program in 2020 and in 2021 we did
recently have camp buck uh which is the
heart of our
diabetes education camp program
we did hold that recently up in south
lake tahoe and it was a very
successfully run camp program nice with
the highest
safety precautions in place
we are returning to our in-person family
support groups
on
uh the first tuesday of every month in
las vegas the las vegas mini grand prix
all right wonderful now we are we're
just about out of time tasha soul that
was a lot of great information but i
know parents are like okay so how do we
get in touch with you how do we get
involved and help our kiddos out here
especially now that they're back in
school so
what are the contact uh numbers and the
websites et cetera the eat the best
okay so the website is www.diabetes.nbc
and also you can reach me tasha thatcher
at our office in las vegas at
702-966-4219
all right
and we do have a fun event coming up on
saturday november 20th okay it's a poker
run at las vegas harley-davidson awesome
tasha thank you so much i really
appreciate it hopefully we brought a
little bit of a little bit more comfort
i should say to
parents who have children in the ccsd
system with diabetes thank you so much
have a great rest of your work week
thank you you too all right folks and
don't forget to catch my moj show
facebook live weeknights at 7 pm yes
sherry i had to i had to come clean i
was doing well
for several years after i reversed my
type 2 diabetes and then i fell off the
wagon and my doctor just last week was
like okay we got to get back up and
running because uh your levels are off
yes and that's uh very serious for you
it is it absolutely is a lot of people
is just putting on some extra pounds
yeah for a diabetic that is really
serious yeah